[Música]
el presidente de perú pedro castillo
cumplió su primer año en el cargo fecha
en la que dio un discurso a la nación
para rendir un balance de su gestión a
lo largo de estos últimos 12 meses el
gobierno de castillo ha estado marcado
por la alta desaprobación de sus
gestiones por parte de la ciudadanía y
también las múltiples investigaciones
judiciales en su contra y la
inestabilidad de su gabinete 59
ministros han pasado por las diferentes
carteras a lo largo de este año de
gobierno veamos más detalles en el
siguiente reporte elaborado por la
redacción de france 24
cinco presidentes en los últimos seis
años en perú un balance que representa
la inestabilidad política en el país
suramericano
principalmente por casos de corrupción
y una de generar un consenso a veces
esta sección de atrás transitoria de
estar renunciando cambiando también es
una pérdida de tiempo decir pero no
avanzar tampoco en 2018 pedro pablo
kuczynski renunció a su cargo en medio
de la presión del congreso 20 meses
después de llegar al sillón presidencial
ahora permanece bajo arresto
domiciliario mientras los fiscales lo
investigan por favorecer contratos con
la constructora brasileña odebrecht
mientras era ministro de economía del ex
presidente alejandro toledo está
denunciado por el polémico indulto al ex
presidente alberto fujimori que
supuestamente concedió a cambio de no
ser destituido
asumió el mando su vicepresidente martín
vizcarra pero en noviembre de 2021 perú
se enfrentó a una compleja crisis
institucional en el marco de una álgida
convulsión social y política
el resultado tres presidentes diferentes
en menos de una semana vizcarra fue
expulsado por los diputados tras ser
acusado de recibir unos 588 mil dólares
en sobornos de dos empresas mientras era
gobernador regional en 2014 lo sucedió
manuel merino quien a tres días de
juramentar en el cargo dimitió en medio
de intensas protestas en el país fue
sustituido por francisco sagasti hasta
las nuevas elecciones en las que pedro
castillo se hizo en el poder pero su
situación no parece ser tan distinta en
un año de gobierno se ha enfrentado a
cinco investigaciones judiciales y dos
mociones de vacancia que aunque ha
logrado superarlas con éxito la
paciencia se agota entre los peruanos
la corrupción sistemática ha quedado
evidenciada en perú en los últimos 30
años 6 de los 10 presidentes que el país
andino ha tenido en ese plazo de tiempo
están acusados de corrupción
durante sus casi dos horas de discurso
dio cifras de logros del gobierno
también habló del inicio de varias obras
de infraestructura y de la planificación
de otras que van a comenzar a hacer
llevadas a cabo en el futuro cercano y
en materia de política exterior resaltó
entre otros temas un acuerdo comercial
alcanzado entre perú y singapur así como
varios programas sociales para
diferentes sectores no hay logros o
resultados contundentes otros sectores
afirmaron que perdió una oportunidad
para desligarse de esos hechos de
corrupción y afianzar un poco su imagen
ante los ciudadanos el mandatario indicó
que ha habido un escenario adverso a su
gestión pero se mostró dispuesto a unir
esfuerzos con otros sectores políticos
para poder trabajar en conjunto por el
país escuchemos este primer año he
recibido una bofetada en una mejilla de
aquellos que no aceptaron perder
legítimamente en las elecciones
presidenciales con el voto consciente
del pueblo peruano pero en este segundo
año no voy a poner la otra mejilla sino
extender la mano para juntos en
beneficio del pueblo
a lo largo de este año castillo ha
tenido una relación tirante con los
medios de comunicación en una ocasión
los calificó de ser un chiste hoy en el
discurso lo señaló de no decir la verdad
e ignorar sus logros no importa que
quienes deberían también informar hayan
ocultado e ignoren nuestros logros y se
dedican a difamar ya mentir acusándonos
sin ninguna prueba y exigiéndonos en una
perversa inversión de los principios
elementales del derecho que problemas
nuestra y que tenemos que probar nuestra
inocencia cuál es entonces el balance de
la gestión de pedro castillo cuáles son
entonces los aspectos positivos es toda
un parte de tranquilidad para esa
incertidumbre política que está viviendo
ese país suramericano desde hace varios
meses tal parece que no convenció a los
ciudadanos ni a las diferentes bancadas
políticas logrará castillo mejorar su
imagen a avanzar en sus planes de
gobierno terminará su mandato o se está
gestando desde ya en el legislativo o
desde otros sectores políticos otra
vacancia lo vamos a analizar aquí en de
france 24 y para conversar sobre este
tema saludamos a milagros campos ella es
profesora de la pontificia universidad
católica y de la universidad san martín
de porres ella se encuentra en la ciudad
de lima en la capital peruana también
desde esta misma ciudad se conecta
roberto chiabra él es congresista del
partido alianza por el progreso y debo
aclarar que el área de producción de
invitados del programa también intentó
contactar a varios congresistas o
políticos oficialistas para conocer la
opinión de ellos desde ese espectro
político pero no quisieron aceptar la
invitación para participar en este
programa solo por mencionar algunos
flavio cruz edgar tello vladimir cerrón
margot palacios álex paredes guido
bellido son algunas de las personas que
contactó en la producción del programa
para tenerlos hoy como invitados para
conocer su punto de vista sobre este
tema les recuerdo que ustedes también
hacen parte de esta conversación dejen
sus preguntas y sus comentarios no
necesitan ser invitados ustedes lo
pueden hacer libremente a través de las
redes sociales estamos en twitter en
instagram y en facebook en donde no se
encuentran con france 4 sant y luego que
es mi cuenta personal la etiqueta a ser
la recuerdo es numeral el debate f 24
también en youtube ustedes pueden seguir
nuestra señal en streaming ya aprovecho
para saludar a las personas que nos
siguen a través del podcast que nos
están escuchando todos nuestros
contenidos ya están disponibles en
diferentes plataformas en app el podcast
en spotify deezer y tuning
comienzo entonces conociendo opiniones
sobre este discurso del estado de la
nación
milagros campos en la ciudad de lima
bienvenida gracias por estar con
nosotros en el programa y punto de
partida una opinión general de lo que se
vivió en la jornada de hoy en perú
opinión líneas generales sobre ese
discurso los puntos que trató el
presidente castillo a lo largo de esas
poco más de dos horas de las que habló
sobre lo que ha hecho a lo largo de este
año
qué tal mi saludo a su audiencia y
también a roberto que ahora quisiera
empezar por señalar que pero está en una
crisis endémica y el mensaje de hoy
debía señalar la situación en que se
encuentra en la república y las
propuestas se hizo un mensaje sin muchas
prioridades creo que de un corte
populista en la medida que empieza
además con un ataque a la prensa que ha
sido señalado y creo que también en un
tema ausente fue la necesidad de la
lucha contra la corrupción pues no
solamente las investigaciones fiscales
sino que en las encuestas se muestran
que una de las preocupaciones más
grandes de la población está vinculada a
la lucha con la corrupta contra la
corrupción el perú tiene una debilidad
institucional que arrastra problemas de
representación política y creo que en
ese ámbito pues no se encuentra este 28
de julio con un congreso muy fragmentado
de alguna manera lo que el presidente
castillo ha logrado es un respaldo en el
congreso que le ha prometido librar esas
mociones de vacancia por permanente
incapacidad moral y creo que en el fondo
los anuncios que se han hecho hoy tienen
que ver con parte de los programas que
ya venían existiendo y promesas
vinculadas a un incremento de sueldos y
a algo aproximado de 10 mil millones que
se van a destinar para otros
efectos pero con efectos pero
básicamente en esa línea diría que el
corte ha sido más bien
populista y con pocas respuestas a las
preguntas que se han hecho en la opinión
pública respecto a su participación en
actos de corrupción
en roberto también en la ciudad de lima
bienvenido al programa el mismo punto de
partida su opinión general sobre este
discurso y los puntos que trató el
presidente castillo en esta rendición de
cuentas sobre su primer año de gestión
bienvenida
estas gracias saludos a milagros gusto
compartir con ella
fíjese si yo le digo de que ha sido un
discurso vacío sin la energía moral
necesaria para hacer los cambios reales
le estoy diciendo lo que ha dicho el
secretario general de su partido
vladimir cerrón y yo junto dos cosas lo
vacío y la falta de moral
15 imagino de los que votaron los que no
votaron por el presidente castillo de
que en menos de un año íbamos a tener
cuatro gabinetes y 56 ministros
no sabía este gobierno que ingresaba que
encontraba un país que había estado
detenido durante dos años por la
pandemia muy mal manejada como ustedes
conocen hemos tenido 200.000 muertos y
que tenemos este año que hemos perdido
dios se hable en el día de ayer que si
queríamos un gran cambio en el
presidente el día de hoy era primero
cambiará el primer ministro y acto el
gabinete porque el primer ministro junto
con él han mantenido durante todo el año
un mensaje de división entre peruanos y
hoy día lo hemos visto la señal no bien
claro milagros al inicio de su discurso
lo primero que hizo es buscar intentar
echar la culpa de su incompetencia como
gobierno a todos antes le echaba la
culpa a la oposición al congreso ahora
le echa la culpa a los medio de
comunicación que no difunden sus éxitos
y últimamente le echaron la culpa al
sistema de justicia como si todos
tuviéramos la culpa de que la corrupción
que él señaló que nos iba a presentar la
tenga tan cerca claro sus familiares y
su secretario general roberto continuó
con usted para hacer la ronda a la
inversa hablemos del tono el presidente
para algunos medios de comunicación
algunos sectores de la sociedad peruana
a través de redes sociales y a través de
los diferentes medios de comunicación
han dicho que el tono del mandatario fue
un poco agresivo un poco a la defensiva
a lo largo de todo su discurso sin
embargo hay que recoger algunas frases
como por ejemplo
abro comillas debo admitir que hemos
cometido errores ahí se muestra un poco
un poco más abierto a reconocer que la
gestión pues tal vez ha tenido algunas
fallas y falencias como califica usted
el tono usado por el presidente y este
reconocimiento este mea culpa sobre
parte de su gestión
pero muy general quienes no es la
primera vez que el presidente señala de
que va a ser un cambio tuvimos un
gabinete que no duró más que tres días y
él señaló que iba a nombrar un primer
ministro
conciliador y nos puso el actual y lo
tanto es así que se reunió con el
arzobispo de huancayo con el presidente
de la fuero nacional y todos esperábamos
que estábamos en mis peores semanas
tanto que semanas antes el cambio yo
espero que ese cambio que ha dicho el
presidente fuera muy general muy suave
no cumpla pero no tiene que cumplir
con programas políticas concretas que es
lo que necesitan la gente los problemas
son muy concretos la solución necesita
ser concreta y necesita un gabinete de
calidad por el beneficio de él y por el
precio de todos los peruanos no podemos
seguir teniendo un nuevo año con esta
gestión de tan poca calidad resultado no
se ven todo lo que hacen al presidente
por ejemplo e incremento por ingresos
por minería es de la gestión anterior
sea porque porque la dos principales
minera de cuajone y las bahamas están
suspendidas todo el año
sobre lo que tiene que cambiar claro
milagros regreso con ustedes allí en la
ciudad de lima esta inestabilidad
política que está presentando perú lo
veíamos en el reporte de contexto que
les presentamos al inicio del programa
no es particular de este gobierno del
gobierno de castillo pero ya viene
inmerso en una espiral de inestabilidad
política desde hace varios años varios
presidentes 5 en total han pasado por
los por por la silla presidencial en los
últimos años pero en el caso puntual de
pedro castillo esta inestabilidad desde
su punto de vista es por la
inexperiencia política por el
desconocimiento en el manejo del estado
o por esa dificultad que ha tenido por
avanzar en políticas y generar una buena
comunicación con la ciudadanía y con los
medios de comunicación y eso es
aprovechado para un revanchismo político
como lo ve usted
en el año pasado creo que comentaba con
justamente sobre un presidente que
propiamente era un outsider porque si
bien había sido candidato por perú
posible para una elección en un pequeño
distrito en cajamarca al interior del
país pues claramente no tenía
experiencia política y había una falta
también de recorrido digamos en algunos
temas esenciales para implementar
políticas públicas pero que vimos además
es que
uno se rodeó de personas que pues
tampoco tenían iniciativa el primer
proyecto de ley en términos de proyectos
con
carácter de políticas públicas se
presentó casi a los tres meses de
gobierno y lo que dijimos es una
confrontación un ensayo sobre la
posibilidad de lanzar una asamblea
constituyente como si fuera una solución
a los problemas de políticas públicas y
a la crisis que traería la pandemia
recordemos que en el perú la pandemia
afectó no solamente en la parte que se
refiere digamos a los problemas de salud
sino que deben los problemas graves
y se construyó a partir de lo que carlos
cano se llamó pues el coronas ok porque
era además arrastrar problemas de tipo
económico y en medio de la crisis
política sobre eso no plantearon
soluciones entonces hay un problema
claro respecto de iniciativa y también
la falta de idoneidad en la selección de
su equipo si hay personas que tenían
denuncias fueron los que se rodearon
entonces no tenemos claramente un
gobierno que haya mostrado
eficacia en la solución de problemas y
más bien una confrontación
creo que innecesaria cuando un
presidente en el perú como ha ocurrido
en los últimos años no tienen mayoría
porque las urnas no le dan una mayoría
no debe tratar de imponer una política
sino buscar determinadas políticas de
consenso para poder gobernar ese es el
mandato que le dio
y hoy el presidente a través de su
discurso tendió la mano a la oposición
para tratar de trabajar en conjunto ese
puente lo está empezando a atender ya
vamos a analizar ese punto y también voy
a analizar el tema del gabinete estos
cincuenta y tantos ministros que han
pasado por las diferentes carteras
quiero conocer la opinión de roberto
sobre sobre este punto en particular que
tanto hay en esta crisis de
inexperiencia del presidente o
desconocimiento del funcionamiento del
estado o que le están poniendo muy
difícil al presidente poder gobernar y
hay cierto grado de revanchismo político
por parte de las diferentes bancadas que
le están entorpeciendo su gobernanza
yo creo que fíjese yo en mis primeros
días que estuve en el congreso yo vi un
ambiente favorable para tener un
consenso de ayudar al ejecutivo porque
no se trataba del presidente que había
ganado la elección si no se trataba de
superar los dos años que hemos estado
obtenido con una crisis a mitad
económica social emocional educacional
ese era la idea y en vez del presidente
aprovechar ese consenso que hay en toda
la bancada para ver cómo apoyamos en su
política encontramos nosotros
incompetencia comenzó a colocar
ministros sin experiencia y gestión sin
conocimiento del sector y con una carga
personal de cuestionamientos que desde
un inicio hubo que interpretar algunos
teníamos uno por ejemplo que desde el
inicio sabíamos que había estado
involucrado en actos de terrorismo como
se podía mantener un ministro de trabajo
con esos antecedentes entonces se
desaprovechó esa oportunidad y se hizo
lo más fácil que han hecho gobiernos
anteriores cubrir sin competencia
echándole la culpa al congreso que
estrategias puntuales nos han presentado
por ejemplo usted ha señalado está
vidrios sabemos nosotros
la seguridad ciudadana es un problema a
nivel nacional y tiene este 7 ministro
en un año y 4 bandas de generales la
policía cada tres meses han cesado a un
comandante general con tres meses como
le produce exigir a la policía que tenga
una estrategia y un plan éxitos de
seguridad ciudadana es su culpa de
guinness del mismo
claro milagros continuó con usted usted
habló de esta necesidad de unificar
esfuerzos de tratar de gobernar no
solamente para ese es a mitad de los
electores peruanos que votaron por él
sino también tratar de generar un poco
de consenso con esa otra mitad de
personas que votaron a favor de la
entonces candidata keiko fujimori el
presidente hoy en el discurso ha
tendido un poco la mano a otros
partidos políticos o bancadas políticas
para tratar de trabajar en conjunto en
pro del país
o lo que uno ve en el escenario de la
lectura del discurso había cierto
rechazo al interior del parlamento o
hasta cierto punto algún sabotaje de
comentarios y se oían
insultos y pues un poco intolerancia
también por parte de los otros partidos
ahí cómo se pueden construir puentes
cuando hay tanta polarización y tanta
división
es cierto que este congreso no solamente
está fragmentado sino que hay una
polarización
pero justamente porque el congreso es un
órgano plural así que este grupo que
representa a una oposición que también
tiene pues una representación clarísima
porque la desaprobación del presidente
castillo llega a 74 por ciento en el
país 74 por ciento
ninguno de los niveles socioeconómicos o
en ninguna de las regiones del país la
aprobación es mayor a la desaprobación
entonces creo que leería este
comportamiento como una manifestación
justamente de los propios parlamentarios
de algo que se percibe en la población
más allá de esto pues creo que ahora tú
para que el presidente de alguna muestra
donde se vea que efectivamente tiende la
mano para buscar acuerdos en
determinadas políticas públicas sin
embargo esto va a ir acompañado de la
necesidad de que brinde explicaciones
respecto de las investigaciones fiscales
que se vienen dando recordemos que en el
facebook
hay un
problema respecto de la responsabilidad
del presidente durante su mandato hay
límites constitucionales
respecto a las causas por las cuales se
le puede acusar durante su mandato
y este ha sido un tema recurrente
durante estos meses entonces creo que
para ir paralelo el hecho de que se
pueda construir alguna decisión de
política pública junto con el hecho de
que se pueda dar cuenta de las
acusaciones y las investigaciones
fiscales que recaen sobre él y su
entorno más cercano no claro sí lo que
no pensaría es que el proceder de las
cosas es que dé explicaciones ante la
justicia por estas investigaciones y
asociaciones en su contra ya veremos
cómo es cómo se desarrollan estas
investigaciones contra el presidente
roberto en la misma pregunta es posible
construir esos esos puentes con la
oposición de usted posible que la
oposición de pronto en pro de sacar el
país de esta espiral de
inestabilidad política se esfuerce por y
ceda un poco también para trabajar en
conjunto o es completamente imposible
debido al grado de desorden que
representa esta administración
fíjese lo que tenemos de lo siguiente la
banca oficialista gran 37 ahora se han
subdividido en cuatro bancadas o sea el
problema de la oposición el problema son
ellos mismos que tiene un mismo se ha
puesto de acuerdo hoy día tiene usted es
el presidente y tiene una bancada
oficialista que es el grupo magisterial
que es de los profesores pero se han
dividido en 4
qué es lo que influye en el presidente
el presidente no toma decisiones no no
no no reconoce errores y el presidente
tiene un serio problema primero se le
cuestiona al presidente por el
nombramiento de su ministro ministro del
interior- ministro de salud ministro de
educación que no estaban con la
capacidad como para enfrentar esta
emergencia que teníamos nosotros y hoy
día tiene serios problemas por la
justicia presidente con 5 denuncias pero
no no por este sospecha ni por ni por
índice hasta por evidencia de la
fiscalía de la nación está haciendo un
trabajo de todos los peruanos estamos
esperando que la justicia esté el nivel
que todos tenemos para que no hayan
tanto corrupto y eso lo que se está
logrando con una nueva fiscal de la
nación que ingresado a nombrar un equipo
de alto nivel entonces el presidente
tiene que dar un gesto pero no de
palabra sino de acción el principio lo
que tiene que hacer cada ministro que
quiere con su estrategia es poner esa
estrategia en el congreso y que congreso
leer las leyes y sobre esa estrategia
con esa ley de la hacemos en control
político no hay planeamiento
entonces tiene usted un divorcio donde
el congreso hace leyes el ejecutivo un
éxito tras leyes sin ningún y luego
conversamos ese giro hay que hacerlo del
otro lado del congreso y el ejecutivo
claro y lo que uno ve en la construcción
de ese gabinete de ministros que ustedes
ya han mencionado que son en algunos
casos personas que no están con el
perfil adecuado para ejercer ese tipo de
funciones el presidente ha llevado
personas que son afín a la izquierda al
marxismo luego se ha movido un poco más
hacia el centro a los progresistas ha
caminado por todos los aspectos por todo
el espectro político peruano tratando de
armar su gabinete y éste no le ha
resultado para tomar las decisiones y
llevar proyectos a cabo un roberto con
este panorama con esta dificultad para
gobernar con esta dificultad para
establecer un gabinete con esta
desconexión que también hay con la
ciudadanía porque claramente los índices
así lo dicen más de un 70 por ciento de
desaprobación esto cómo afecta la
institucionalidad peruana cómo afecta la
democracia peruana que ya viene con
serios problemas desde hace gobiernos
atrás
yo te dio tenes resumir en lo siguiente
la corrupción mató la dignidad de los
peruanos y la corrupción forma
producción de la versal desde los años
80 y la corrupción se llevó de encuentro
a los políticos a los empresarios a todo
se lo digo de encuentro lo que se
esperaba era que el presidente que
castillo dijo de que no se iba a
presentar y tuviéramos nosotros una
justicia y un presidente que combatirán
fuertemente el acuerdo si no lo ha hecho
el primer el primer sospechoso es el
entonces la gente es intensa y
desilusión porque lo pero no no nos
molesta tanto a la corrupción siendo la
impunidad porque nosotros decimos porque
tanto corruptos porque sabe que no le va
a pasar nada bueno con con el cambio en
los sistema de justicia y creo que va a
cambiar entonces el presidente tiene que
dar un paso y si usted tiene un primer
ministro con un permanente mensaje de
división ahí en colombia en otros sitios
hacen lo que se llama el consejo de
ministros descentralizado usted no puede
ir a todas las regiones del país a
dividir a los peruanos a decir que el
congreso tiene la culpa que los limeños
y los provincianos los pobres y los
ricos los buenos y los malos
y una unidad para salir en la crisis si
usted y debe liderar hacia la división
clark milagro su opinión lo que esto
genera en la democracia peruana y lo que
genera en la institucionalidad un país
que le ha costado mucho estabilizarse lo
vemos desde hace varios años esto qué
repercusiones puede tener en el mediano
y largo plazo para la política peruana
pues creo que es necesario pensar en
hacer ciertas reformas institucionales
que permitan fortalecer a los partidos
políticos pero también ya no pasando por
medidas legislativas creo que es
necesario entender uno que no se puede
gobernar sin el congreso y que eso no
significa solamente votos que protejan
al presidente para evitar la vacancia
sino que hacer que sus políticas a
aquello que postulan los otros grupos
políticos es la única manera de
encontrar un diálogo y consenso y lo
segundo es que el presidente no puede
gobernar de espaldas a la transparencia
y a medidas preventivas de actos de
corrupción en realidad más allá del
marco normativo lo que se requiere es un
presidente que sepa reportar que sepa
realmente comunicar y eso lo puede hacer
a través de la prensa no puede
gobernar
sin respetar la libertad de prensa y
ello significa pues no incurrir en
quejas sino más bien responder a las
preguntas interrogantes que la prensa le
hace porque sabemos que tampoco hay
democracia sin una irrestricta libertad
de prensa milagros que bueno que usted
toca ese tema porque era una de mis
preguntas y es esa difícil relación que
tiene con los medios de comunicación
allí en perú en los a criticados los ha
señalado en este discurso también
aprovecho para volverlos a señalar y
hacer críticas sobre la gestión que
hacen y sobre el manejo de la
información pero él tampoco ha sido el
mandatario más fácil para entregar
información no ha sido tampoco el más
fácil para dar entrevistas o responder
preguntas como usted lo no lo mencionaba
y cuando lo ha hecho no le ha salido
bien esa entrevista que dio a cnn en
español y ha jugado en contra por las
declaraciones que dio y el mandatario se
ha blindado un poco frente a los medios
de comunicación esto también en que
repercute en esa construcción de
democracia y cómo afecta esto
directamente a los ciudadanos que son
quienes se quedan aquí sin poder obtener
respuestas directamente el presidente
a través de los medios
es que el correlato de la libertad de
prensa es la libertad de los ciudadanos
para formar opinión y estar informados
es esa libertad de información la que se
encuentra el riesgo cuando vemos además
que cuando él se dirige en mítines o en
reuniones al interior del país critica
al congreso critica a la prensa y además
promueve una constituyente que en verdad
la gente no reclama lo que se busca más
bien es solucionar los problemas de
gestión no es posible que tengamos colas
para filas inmensas para lograr obtener
un pasaporte un tema que en el perú
desde hace muchos años se obtenía el
mismo día este tipo de problemas de
gestión son a los que me refiero y que
hacen el día a día de los ciudadanos
también ha ocurrido que se ha
despedido a mucha gente en
administración pública gente que venía
de distintos gobiernos y que no
respondía a un partido político sino que
me refiero al servicio civil a la
burocracia que sostiene la
administración pública es necesario
fortalecerla y no buscar llenar de
partidos o pensar en mezclar el mar
tienen de largo voy llegando ya al
último tramo del programa roberto este
discurso que le deja a usted qué
sensación le deja que el presidente
estaba tratando de simplemente salvarse
en mantenerse y no dar solución a la
crisis inminente a la que se está
enfrentando el país
que le dice a usted como ciudadano
peruano como reciben este discurso los
ciudadanos
yo creo que la mayoría por no decir
todos esperamos una autocrítica un
reconocimiento el presidente no ha
sabido entender el momento que estamos
viviendo y que está viviendo él por el
bien del país nosotros necesitamos un
presidente que esté acá liderazgo que
genere confianza que genere esperanza
que él mismo señales de que va a volver
a unir a los peruanos es lo que
presentamos nosotros él cree que le da
un mensaje al congreso este mensaje lo
escucha auto el perú o la cadena de
radio el congreso por todos lados y él
ha debido de darse cuenta que este
mensaje el perú lo que buscaban los
peruanos que conoces cuáles son esas
estrategias puntuales que el presidente
va a señalar como un gran cambio para
superar la inseguridad ciudadana la
crisis alimentaria la falta de trabajo
no lo hemos visto
el presidente
desaprovechar las oportunidades porque
presiente no de tomar como una
obligación salir a un medio y aclarar
cuando se le cuestiona por ejemplo los
casos de corrupción principio tiene que
darse cuenta y coincidimos el presidente
no se asesora bien claro que sí que está
mal asesorado yo creo que el presidente
tiene que darse cuenta
y si tiene que cambiar y basta que el
cambio para que cambie todo si tal
parece en resumen de seis cursos que él
trató de salir a la defensa para
solucionar su crisis y no la crisis y la
necesidad del país que es tal vez lo que
reclaman por supuesto los peruanos
milagros su opinión sobre este balance
el mandatario salió a defenderse el
defendió la tratar de dar soluciones a
esta crisis y como recibirán los
ciudadanos peruanos este discurso que ya
están cansados de la crisis política
también desconectados un poco de todo
este entramado político que lleva viendo
el país en los últimos años
una de las últimas encuestas muestra que
la gran preocupación de las personas es
el costo de vida evidentemente por
razones externas pero también por la
crisis política en el perú las
expectativas de crecimiento han bajado
el dólar ha subido desde que casi igual
poder también pero es cierto que hay
razones externas sin embargo esas
razones externas requieren de medidas
concretas hoy hemos visto que la
inflación que se prevé el la prolonga
inversión privada que se prevé para el
segundo semestre es cinco puntos menores
a lo que se preveía
es decir se requiere de mensaje
consistente que de cierta seguridad para
mejorar la calidad de vida de los
peruanos en términos económicos porque
también la inflación ha llegado a
niveles que no se conocían y la pobreza
se ha incrementado entonces creo que ese
es un punto central para ver hacia dónde
enfocar las medidas de políticas
públicas del presidente
hemos escuchado poco han sido una una
apelación de cifras pero pocas
prioridades que puedan llegar a la
población para saber qué esperar quedan
ya un par de minutos para finalizar el
programa siempre lo digo al cierre no
tenemos una bola de cristal para saber
qué va a pasar en el futuro menos en el
futuro político de perú que cualquier
cosa puede pasar así no lo ha demostrado
a lo largo de los últimos años pero
entonces cierro con esta pregunta para
que hagan las conclusiones milagros y
roberto de castillo va a terminar su
mandato porque por mucho menos sacaron a
vizcarra el poder y el escenario parece
mucho más complicado para castillo
muchos sectores de perú esperaban hoy
una renuncia o un llamado a elecciones
eso no sucedió el presidente terminará o
no comienzo con milagros para el cierre
para la conclusión no me atrevería a dar
una respuesta al respecto es que
efectivamente por mucho menos salió
pedro pablo kuczynski y salió mal y
vizcarra
ambos están con procesos abiertos y creo
que el tema acá es encontrar la clave
para la gobernabilidad democrática y
sólo veo que se pueda conseguir con una
transparencia adecuada y con respuestas
que satisfagan a las necesidades de
mantener una política que se enfoque en
políticas públicas y en menos
confrontación y no podría responder a
esa pregunta es muy incierto lo que
puede pasar en el perú en los próximos
meses y roberto su conclusión finalizará
el mandato el presidente del castillo y
dice hay dos verdades el presidente no
va a renunciar ni va a adelantar
elecciones porque es su seguro de
libertad el presiente seguir mientras
que esté en el cargo y me seguro de
libertad porque termine en el cargo
mañana ha pasado el 2026 ya sabe lo que
le va a pasar la pregunta que nos
hacemos todos en el presente porque se
mantiene en el cargo por su calidad
gestión no porque no hay 87 votos en el
congreso para carlos permanente
incapacidad moral si la fiscalía de la
nación sigue a este ritmo y hace una
conclusión preliminar que lo involucre
presidente yo creo que los congresistas
que hasta ahora votan en contra la
vacancia van a cambiar de opinión y de
repente llegamos a los 87 votos más
corto de los pensados
pues a roberto chiabra y a milagros
campos en la ciudad de lima les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros en el debate haber hecho este
análisis de este discurso del primer año
de gestión del presidente castillo allí
en este país suramericano difícil el
escenario político en este país
inestabilidad política lo que ha reinado
allí a lo largo de los últimos años
muchísimas gracias por haber aclarado
estos diferentes puntos para la
audiencia de france 24 reitero invitamos
también a este programa a diferentes
políticos y congresistas de la bancada
oficialista hicieron desde la producción
del programa diferentes llamados y
ninguna de estas personas contactadas
quiso participar en este programa para
dar el punto de vista oficialista sobre
este discurso que dio el presidente
castillo a los peruanos sobre la gestión
estos 365 días 12 meses de gestión su
primer año en el gobierno usted puede
seguir dejando sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
ya las conocen y pueden seguir por
supuesto con la programación de france
24 sigan con nosotros
[Música]